[Musik]
ein wunderschöner Morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen
ich weiß dass du da bist
das weiß ich auch weil ich dich in der
letzten Folge umgedreht habe ich wünsche
Dir auch einen schönen Tag wir sehen uns
Mr Pepper ich habe für heute ein
riesiges Projekt vor und es seht ihr
bereits im Titel eingeblendet denn ich
möchte heute endlich unsere Villa
fertigstellen da haben wir ja noch immer
nicht das Dach fertig gebaut wir haben
das Interieur noch nicht fertig und ich
weiß dass das wahrscheinlich sehr lange
dauern wird und die Folge wird heute
vermutlich für mich in
das kann sein aber ich setze mir
lieber zu hohe Ziele setzen und die nur
zu einem Teil erreichen als dass ihr
euch ein kleines Ziel setzt und das
Erreichte komplett
[Musik]
ich bin auf dem Weg meine lieben Freunde
euch direkt jetzt eine riesige timelapse
die ich in die Hölle gehe und quarzfarme
da ich nun wirklich eine Stunde lang im
netherquarz Farmen war habt ihr euch mal
wieder einen Witz von mir verdient und
zwar Leute ich kann es wirklich immer
noch nicht fassen dass die nach dem
ganzen Scheiß wieder zusammen sind ihr
fragt mich jetzt wahrscheinlich von wem
ich rede von meinen Arschbacken
oh mein Gott Freunde
eine komplette Stunde
eine Stunde und zehn Minuten lang war
ich gerade mit Sandra hier unterwegs in
der Hölle und habe ein zwei drei
vielleicht insgesamt vier Stacks Quarz
abgebaut wirkt jetzt nicht so viel liegt
allerdings auch einfach daran dass ich
mit meiner Glück einspitzhacke alles
abbauen musste ich habe extra die Glück
drei Spitzhacke Diamanten und den Amboss
mitgenommen ich habe 45 Level jedoch
konnte ich trotzdem nicht meine Glück
drei Spitzhacke reparieren Minecraft hat
mir immer gesagt Mensch egal das ist zu
teuer von daher Freunde bitte schreibt
mir bitte bitte bitte natürlich jetzt
auch wieder Nacht äh bitte schreibt mir
unten in die Kommentare was ich falsch
mache ich will meine Glück drei Diamant
Spitzhacke zurück ich weiß nicht ob die
ob das mit dazu nehmenden nutzen
Nutzungsdauer mit zunehmender
Nutzungsdauer ob es dadurch teurer wird
die jedes Mal zu reparieren ich weiß es
jetzt wieder alle schreiben werden ey du
brauchst ein Reparaturbuch Blabla ja da
arbeite ich auf der anderen Seite dran
mit dem Bibliothekar können wir auch
gleich mal ganz kurz gucken ob der da
neue Sachen hat allerdings ich sitz den
Amboss hier hin packe die Glücks drei
Spitzhacke rein zu teuer ey ich habe 60
Diamanten und 45 Level und das kann doch
nicht sein also wir gehen mal ganz kurz
rüber zu unserem
Bibliothekar und nehmen auch mal ganz
kurz einiges Smaragde mit dann kann ich
das ja eben ganz fix schon mal eben
abklären plus ich kann mir hier vorne
auch schon eben die Sachen wieder
rausnehmen und so ein bisschen
quarzblöcke schon mal nachlegen ich habe
da extra Lava einmal reingepackt in der
letzten Episode habt ihr ja mitbekommen
so dass wir hier ein bisschen mehr sage
ich mal wo ist denn der Rest
den habe ich in der letzten Folge schon
rausgenommen oder zu Beginn der Folge
ich weiß es nicht damit wir auf jeden
Fall ein bisschen mehr Power haben die
wir hier packe ich auch mal ganz fix
eben zurück hier vorne zu den anderen
quarzblöcken wo habe ich die denn hin
gepackt
bin ich komplett dumm
[Musik]
hä
komplett bescheuert eine Stunde später
die waren noch in den Öfen was ich alles
gerade sagen wollte ich bin so ein Dummy
wann das kannst du noch keinem erzählen
warum guckt man sich dieses Projekt
überhaupt an was ich allerdings gerade
machen wollte war mal kurz in ihr fragen
ob er Rückstoß Verbrennung Stärke 3 auch
sehr wild aber sonst gar nichts äh das
Namensschild brauchen wir allerdings
trotzdem das werde ich allerdings nicht
jetzt kaufen sondern in der nächsten
Episode was ich damit genau machen werde
erfahrt ihr dann ich werde nun
allerdings meine quarzblöcke nehmen bzw
erstmal ganz kurz noch schnell meine
Items sortieren
so sieht unsere Strandvilla ja aktuell
aus da fehlt halt noch das Dach oben
drauf
und darauf ich habe meine Spitzhacke
vergessen
ich brauche eine
behutsamkeits-spitzhacke denn ich habe
ja hier vorne noch eine Menge Glas und
ich will dafür eigentlich nicht meine
Gold
behutsamkeitsspitzhacke verschwenden
weil die direkt wieder die wird die
regiert direkt wieder kaputt von daher
würde ich sagen arbeiten wir jetzt
einfach mit eisenspitzhacken die wir
versuchen zu verzaubern von daher nehme
ich mal ganz kurz meine Stecker dann
nehme ich hier die Eisenbarren mit und
ich werde jetzt auch einfach mal die
Werkbank mitnehmen so dass wir dann
alles da vorne direkt auf der Insel
machen können wir brauchen wirklich
Behutsamkeit das wäre halt so nice oder
habe ich nicht noch irgendwas hier mit
Behutsamkeit Verzauberung drauf oder so
hier ist halt Behutsamkeit drauf aber
hier ist ein Effizienz und Haltbarkeit
Glück und hier ist ein ganz normaler
eisenspitzhacke also wir können auch
erstmal ganz kurz unsere Schuhe wieder
tauschen die Sache ist ich bin schon
total durch mit der folge ich bin bei
eineinhalb Stunden im Video ist es
wahrscheinlich allerdings gerade mal
Minute fünf oder irgendwie so und das
ist gerade so ein bisschen das Problem
ich will dieses Video hier heute nicht
kurz halten weil ich eigentlich ja noch
eine Menge schaffen muss mit der Villa
allerdings werde ich jetzt erstmal ganz
kurz hier probieren mit der Werkbank und
dann meiner neuen Spitzhacke
Behutsamkeit darauf zu bekommen also ab
rein in den Marsch und wir haben
Effizienz Haltbarkeit und Effizienz
wir können es halt probieren mit
Effizienz 4 noch
ich glaube das wird nichts ich glaube
das wird nichts wir werden uns
dementsprechend darauf nachher
konzentrieren und uns jetzt erstmal auf
das Dach unserer Villa konzentrieren
jetzt habe ich zweimal konzentrieren
gesagt
fokussieren
heute ein Ford Focus gesehen Alter
tiefergelegt so eine Dreckskarre sorry
an alle die zu Hause und Ford Focus
stehen haben falls ihr euch jetzt gerade
beleidigt haben sollte es ist ein
wunderschönes Auto allerdings sieht kein
Auto extrem tiefer gelegt in neongrün
schön aus da kannst du auch ein Porsche
sein oder ein Lamborghini oder keine
Ahnung was naja ihr seht schon ich baue
hier oben gerade mal das Dach so ein
bisschen zu sodass wir hier hinten auf
jeden Fall erstmal keinen Regen mehr im
Hause drin haben die Sache ist dass ich
zu Beginn ein bisschen Schiss hatte dass
ich das überhaupt schaffe mit der
glückseinspitzen Glück eins Spitzhacke
den ganzen Quarz abzubauen den wir
benötigen für diese Strandhaus Villa die
Sache ist allerdings dass wir ja auch
noch hier oben gleich eine kleine ja wie
nennt man das so ein kleines
Panoramadach reinbauen werden und an der
Seite auch noch von daher benötigen wir
eigentlich gar nicht so viele
quarzblöcke wie ich mir das zu Beginn
gedacht habe diese sechseinhalb sechs
was ich da vor zwei Folgen meinte
sondern das werden wir auch mit ein
bisschen weniger hinkriegen habe ich
mich gerade zweimal verbaut von daher
ähm kann ich euch schon mal sagen hier
vorne kommt gleich Sonne Wand äh aus
Glas rein die wir hier rüberziehen und
hier auch noch hier vorne in der Ecke
das hier muss allerdings weg das lass
ich jedoch jetzt erstmal gerade stehen
und bis wir das Interieur machen in
einer der nächsten Folgen ich weiß es im
Titel steht die Villa ist fertig die
Sache ist allerdings dass ich damit
meine dass der Rohbau fertig ist also es
ist interior Interior Design kommt
später naja da werden wir uns nachher
noch drum kümmern wenn jetzt auch gleich
mein schwarz leer ist werde ich direkt
rüber gehen ich verbaue mich auch die
ganze Zeit irgendwie gerade ne wenn man
quasi ich leer ist werde ich auch
rübergehen wenn das andere Quarz holen
und dann noch mal kurz ein bisschen Glas
machen damit wir das vielleicht heute
auch sogar schon fertig kriegen mit den
Glasfenstern die Sache ist jedoch ich
sage so auf die Sache ist allerdings
oder ich sage jetzt hier doch oder
irgendwie so
ganz kurze timeless ist ja gerade
überhaupt nicht spannend timelapse wie
ich das Ding hier zu baue den anderen
Quarz oder Glas mache und dann sehen wir
uns sofort wieder
[Musik]
so ich konnte jetzt leider nicht das
komplette Glas fertig machen was ich
benötige für meine Villa allerdings habe
oh wir haben ungebeten eine Gäste hier
heute Madame bitte habe Dieseln sie sich
äh haben wir noch mehr wir haben hier
noch einen Skelett wir haben jetzt aber
kein Creeper oder so das wird uns jetzt
natürlich komplett hier die Tour
versauen zack hier vorne wartet auch
niemand in dem Raum dahinter weiß ich
halt nicht was da abgeht wenn man ganz
kurz gucken alle haben extra Fackeln
eingesetzt perfekt ja das Glas hier
bräuchte ich eigentlich um das erstmal
ganz kurz hier oben alles zu bauen um
das hier vorne rüber zu bauen die Sache
ist jetzt auch warum habe ich mir denn
so viele glatte quarzblöcke gemacht ach
so weil ich das hier alles noch voll
bauen musste das heißt ich würde sagen
wir nehmen jetzt erstmal unsere
goldspitzhacke und machen das hier so
gut es geht bis das Ding kaputt ist das
heißt wahrscheinlich wir können ja 8
Blöcke abbauen oder so wie ich unsere
goldspitzhacke kenne die ist nämlich
jetzt schon wieder fast Schrott und zwar
genau kann ich jetzt aufhören
ich dachte ein Block schafft die noch
jetzt ist einfach kaputt
naja ist hier vorne noch Glas
reingefallen ja natürlich hier haben wir
noch ein Glasblock hier und hier vorne
es scheidet halt nicht am Glas dass sich
das mit dem mit der Glaswand heute nicht
so richtig glaube ich hinkriege es
scheitert halt ganz einfach daran dass
ich keine Tintenfische hier sehe die ich
leider töten muss um die Tintenbeutel zu
bekommen denn das ist die einzige
Möglichkeit um einen Block schwarz zu
färben und hier ist nirgendwo weit und
breit ein Tintenfisch und das regt mich
einfach extrem auf von daher müssen wir
jetzt erstmal leider mit dem arbeiten
was wir hier noch haben und daher nun
erstmal die glatten quarzblöcke hier
vorne rein den Rest hier werde ich jetzt
einfach dann abbauen glaube ich da habe
ich gar keinen Bock drauf mich jetzt
irgendwie lange damit zu beschäftigen
kann man das eigentlich irgendwie
schneller abbauen
so meine lieben Freunde hier wieder eine
halbe timelaps folge ich glaube das
Video geht wirklich noch gar nicht lang
allerdings habe ich ja ich nehme das
ganze jetzt schon seit einer Stunde 45
auf ich muss hier vorne auf jeden Fall
erstmal provisorischen paar Fackeln
reinsetzen so dass hier nichts weiter
spawnt am hellichten Tag ich sehe einen
tintenfischer muss ich direkt hin jetzt
muss ich aber das hier erstmal in die
linke Hand wieder nehmen äh mir ist ja
auch gerade ein quarzblock
runtergefallen ich weiß nicht hier vorne
ist er perfekt so jetzt müssen wir ganz
kurz zum
[Musik]
wo habe ich denn denn gesehen
bin ich blöd
aber doch gerade einen Tintenfisch
[Musik]
da ist er auch
zwei
das heißt vielleicht schaffen wir das
doch mit der kompletten fenstersituation
heute meine lieben Freunde der hat
allerdings gerade kein Insekt gedroppt
ich weiß nicht ob ich den einfach noch
nicht aufgenommen habe oder ist der ISA
perfekt sogar zwei Stück perfekt so hier
vorne der bitte auch noch zwei Stück
dann können es wirklich was werden heute
mit den Fenstern die schwimmen immer
extrem schnell weg wenn man die einmal
schlägt nochmal zwei perfekt wir haben
vier Stück sehen wir vielleicht noch
irgendwo hinten Fische nee ist leider
nicht der Fall von daher meine lieben
Freunde werde ich mich nun hinten hin oh
mein Gott ein dritter Tintenfisch Alter
als wieso als wenn Minecraft mir gesagt
hätte kommen Luca gönn dir sieben Stück
habe ich da hinten sogar noch einen
Delfin noch ein alter was geht denn
jetzt ab ich schwöre timelapse
eingeblendet gesehen also ich kann gar
nicht gecheatet haben aber ich habe die
da nicht hin platziert oder irgendwas
gemacht das ist einfach gerade es ist
einfach wieder mein Glück in Minecraft
also ich habe sieben Stück das heißt ich
kann mit erstmal nach ganz hinten laufen
und ein bisschen Glas holen ich kann mir
aus dem ganzen jetzt eineinhalb Stacks
schwarzes Glas machen und ich glaube
dass das zumindest für die Scheibe links
erstmal reichen sollte ich weiß nicht ob
das für das Panorama darauf der anderen
Seite reicht allerdings sehen wir ja
vielleicht irgendwo noch ein paar
Delfine ach delfine sind hier der viele
töte vielleicht sehen wir ja irgendwo
noch ein paar Tintenfische rumschwimmen
das wäre auf jeden Fall extrem nice dann
können wir das machen ich habe auch den
glatten Sandstein mitgenommen dann
können wir eventuell noch unseren
kleinen provisorischen Sand hier noch
ein bisschen erweitern hier vorne kommt
auch noch ein Pool hin kommt alles
können wir heute nicht komplett
vollenden allerdings ist der Rohbau
heute auf jeden Fall erstmal fertig von
daher müssen wir uns nun erstmal nach
hier vorne bewegen ich habe mich auch
schon perfekt rausgebaut denn wir
brauchen hier 1 2 3 4 5 6 breit soll das
Ganze gehen dann müssen wir das ganze
jetzt hoch bauen und jetzt von hier aus
zehn Blöcke rüber in die Richtung und
diesen Bereich hier jetzt füllen mit
schwarzen Glas so dass das ganze dann
schlussendlich so aussieht und das wird
von außen sowohl als von innen auch
extrem geil aussehen ich platziere mal
hier genau mal ganz kurz eine Fackel wie
gesagt alles nur hier provisorisch das
hat jetzt überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben
allerdings sieht ihr schon das sieht so
wild aus hier vorne hier kommt da noch
eine kleine Ablage hin und so das Baum
dann alles demnächst wie gesagt in Tirol
Design kommt noch allerdings bauen wir
jetzt für hier vorne auch noch eine
kleine Glasfläche rein denn dafür setzen
wir uns erstmal
1234123 hier so eine kleine Markierung
rein so dass wir genau wissen wo wir das
genau abbauen müssen und jetzt in diesem
Bereich ein eins zwei drei vier fünf mal
eins zwei drei vier fünf großes Quadrat
also 1 2 3 4 5 in diese Richtung dann
zwei drei vier fünf hier rein dafür habe
ich jetzt leider zu wenig schwarzes Glas
mir fehlen genau drei Stück und hier
vorne kommt auch noch was rein also ich
bin leider was das hier angeht gerade
ein bisschen schlecht aufgestellt ich
bau allerdings ganz kurz mal eben diesen
glatten sandturm hier noch mal ab
glatten Sandstein Turm noch mal ab und
hier vorne da müssen wir gleich auch
noch was machen die Sache ist allerdings
ich gerade irgendwo in Delfin gesehen
habe ich weiß jedoch nicht mehr wo das
war oder ob der wieder untergetaucht ist
da habe ich du die denn leider verloren
und dieses eine diesen einen hat hinten
Beutel brauche ich wirklich noch dann
habe ich es für heute geschafft meine
lieben Freunde ich finde ihn allerdings
einfach nicht ich weiß nicht warum ich
jetzt gerade so am struggle mit hinten
Beuteln ich hatte doch irgendwie so viel
schwarzes Glas Alter das habe ich
wahrscheinlich hierhin gebaut ne und
komplett verbaut naja hier muss doch
irgendwo noch einen Tintenfisch sein ey
dann kriegen wir das auf jeden Fall für
heute noch fertig ich laufe noch einmal
schnell um die Villa rum achte um die
Villa rum um unsere Insel rum allerdings
kann ich euch ja gleich hier vorne schon
mal die Villa von dieser Insel hier
zeigen so dass sie dann in etwa euch
schon vorstellen könnt wo die Reise
hingeht also ich bin
ehrlich gesagt ich bin zufrieden mit der
Villa ich hätte allerdings nicht gedacht
dass es so lange dauert
es wird sehr wild aussehen wenn da oben
noch interior drin ist und dann hier die
Fackeln weg und so das wird sehr sehr
geil
ist halt nur schade dass es jetzt
irgendwie an so einem so ein bisschen
Glas hier habe hat ne ist aber auch egal
meine lieben Freunde dann soll es
anscheinend nicht sein ich nehme hier
vorne mal eben noch fix die Sachen raus
die hier noch drin waren haben wir noch
eine Menge Glas drin und ein bisschen
glatten Sandstein ich schaue mal kurz
hier vorne ob ihr irgendwo und hinten
Fisch ist die dieses Hühnchen ist auch
viel zu blöd um hier rauszukommen ich
habe extra schon den Block vorhin mal
abgebaut allerdings sehe ich hier
wirklich keinen Tintenfisch ey wenn man
die nicht braucht dann schwimmen die
überall rum diese blöden Thunfische aber
mal dann braucht man wieder so ein
Tintenbeutel wieder weg also ich habe
keine Ahnung was das hier soll warum ich
jetzt hier so hops genommen werde von
dem Spiel mal wieder aber ich hatte ja
vorhin auf dem riesigen riesiges Glück
mit den ganzen Tintenfischen aber einen
Thunfisch brauchen wir noch
es kann nicht sein
kein einziger gesagt
[Musik]
du bist ein
okay das natürlich auch eine gute Arten
Streits lösen ja meine lieben Freunde
ich weiß ich habe den Titel geschrieben
die Villa ist fertig und die Villa ist
auch mehr oder weniger fertig also ihr
seht die ja von hier schon das sieht
brutal aus klar da oben der glatte
Sandstein muss er weg und hier kommt ein
anderer Durchgang durch und ich habe
auch viel zu viel Quarz mittlerweile ich
habe noch dreieinhalb Stacks allerdings
würde ich an der Stelle des heutigen
Video jetzt auch beenden meine lieben
Freunde und ich habe auch eine kleine
Bitte an Euch denn für die nächste
Episode Minecraft mit Luca habe ich mir
gedacht mache ich eine kleine Frage
Runde und er schreibt mir jetzt eure
Fragen bezogen auf dieses Projekt und in
die Kommentare es kann was mit Schnitt
zu tun haben mit wie lange geht es noch
mit irgendwas was euch einfällt was euch
interessiert an Minecraft mit Luca
schreibt mir gerne unten in die
Kommentare und wenn euch das Video heute
gefallen hat dann lasst gern einen
Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke so dass ihr die nächstes die
nächsten Part nicht verpasst wo ich dann
diese XXL Fragen Runde mache übermorgen
20 Uhr haut rein tschüssi
[Musik]